at the end of time
[Music]
[Applause]
13. o'clock
what's up folks it's Wednesday night me
and Jay were talking about how awesome
that intro is every time like I'm just
I'm patting myself on the back good work
Jenny good work well I said well the old
one I didn't mind the old one but the
thing about the old one was that I had
to use just kind of like free video
clips that I could find so you just kind
of had to use what you found but I
actually pay nowadays because I do like
so many more videos
I decided I was gonna break down and buy
a storyblocks subscription which is not
cheap it's like 300 a year
um but they have really really good
video clips of pretty much everything
and you can use them in all of your
projects so that's so I could get like
access to better stuff you know what I
mean you got to pay for good stuff
sometimes because the free [__]
doesn't always what is that noise is
this [__] what is this [__] gonna be
doing I heard that noise earlier and I
was like what the [__] is that
oh [__] now we're now we're hearing
ourselves [__] oh my God okay you've got
all share problems it should be it's
giving me [__] notification sounds I
didn't ask for any of that
it just does it it just does it my phone
does random [__] too yeah like just hey
this noise is on now yeah somebody said
something about you on Instagram and
you're like I don't give a [__] I'm
[__] streaming the thing about my
phone is that you can either I swear to
God like when I want to do something on
it like I said they're poke at it and it
won't do anything but then other times I
breathe on it and it does all kind of
crazy [__] I don't really know it's it's
all kind of like I don't know let's see
who's in uh murder Hornet said new intro
well we did a new intro
um
well yeah when did we started like
around New Year's right around New
Year's yeah we did so it's been like
been a while a while a couple of months
anyway but yeah yeah I'm just every time
every time I see it like every week I'm
like man that came out really good I was
like really proud of myself because I'm
not you know I'm not like a Master Video
Editor or anything like that I just kind
of
Cobble things together you know
it's going to be an interesting show
today
I thought so too yeah do you have any
shout outs or anything to anybody uh we
yes we have a new Patron
named die I think or day d-a-e day yeah
uh so yeah thank you very much new 10
Patron thank you Dave so that's our
newest one in a while that's pretty
awesome
pretty awesome
uh so yeah granther says question
between mannequins and barbarellas how
many randos hit on Sophie over the
weekend
uh uh no but I don't think anybody hit
on her at Barbarella because that's not
there they hit a couple guys moves with
her yeah yeah yeah but that's not
hitting the same thing that's not really
the same thing yeah they're all fishing
though well yeah
um well you guys [__] went back and
go back and look [__] they're
grabbing Jenny's ass had to slap one
dude right that was mannequins
Barbarella and then dude other dude just
[__] tried to get in on him and I was
just backed him up like that and [__]
had whip his ass
yeah yeah it's a whole funny I had a
superhero day today I went to go went to
go see my friend Dan he's uh he's my uh
[__] muscle porn star [__] drug
dealer and I was good but uh yeah yeah
just I get my medication from him you
know what I mean and uh he's like uh I
told him that deal he goes oh yeah yeah
that's gonna happen all the time and I'm
like wait but what
laughs he goes yeah you can Wade through
three or four guys if they're not
working out or they're not on anything
they're just you just it's like it's
like fighting kids it's like fighting
little kids or something
and and I'll say so it's just people who
are working out and
[__] doing steroids and [__] and he's
like yeah that's the only way you have
to worry about and people with guns
that's all that's all he said
but he's just it's just [__] funny
man it's a life-changing event how easy
it is
but um nah just
that night that was not a normal night
for mannequins it was just that was a
particularly bad night for creeps
and evidently it had been getting kind
of that way
steadily the past a few weeks evidently
but we just we may not go back there
I don't know we'll see yeah
a lot of people are going just because
uh just because of that
yeah because of that kind of that kind
of dude yeah yeah they're like too many
they're just thirsty and [__] don't
know how to act in a club they don't
have any club culture they're just you
know Bros dude Bros and they're not
really sure where they are and
don't know how to act and no game you
know
Ben said I guess this is in reaction to
what you said about this is going to be
an interesting show you said oh good
sick of the boring shoes
I mean I like to think about their shoes
are interesting yeah but well I've been
wanting to like I said I've been wanting
to do this topic for a while and it
finally won the poll
but because I only found out about this
probably like a year or two ago yeah and
it always makes me really sad like when
somebody who did something awesome or
like something kind of like world
changing got [__] over and this guy
really got [__] up he not only got
[__] over but he uh disappeared and
nobody knows where he is well was he's
clearly dead now because it was like
19th century but I'm glad that it's you
know it's the same thing do you know
like many many years ago did you learn
about Nikola Tesla at school like when
you were a kid
I don't think I did either but
um you know over the years people have
actually you know like realized Tesla's
contributions to the culture as a whole
you learned about Edison and now well
yeah and that's kind of what I want to
talk about here because Thomas Edison's
ass might be involved in this as well
um I don't know like I don't really know
how I stand on it if you if you know the
story like you kind of know what where
I'm going with it but Thomas Edison I
remember being in school
but just like Elementary School junior
high and stuff like that and talk about
how [__] awesome like Thomas Edison
was he invented this he invented that he
invented the other thing and then like
when you get a little bit older and now
I kind of feel like this knowledge is
seeping into the culture as a whole
Thomas Edison kind of a [__]
um didn't really invent a lot of things
per se as like stealing other people's
ideas doing shady [__] with uh patent
law
um you know just screwing people over
essentially not really having any
Scruples or ethics about that kind of
thing and uh you know he [__] over a
lot of people and a lot of people that
invented things uh you know died
penniless yeah because yeah because of
[__] that he did yeah and uh that's
basically where we're at
with this story I don't know like I said
if Thomas Edison was involved in what
happened to Louis laprince or not but
I will say that Thomas Edison probably
stood to gain the most from him
Vanishing I will say that but that
doesn't mean that he had anything to do
with it I wouldn't put it past the
[__] that's for sure but I don't know
we'll get into that I mean it may be
something completely different it may be
something completely random we'll get
into like because there's a couple
different theories about what might have
happened to him but we'll kind of get
into that uh Trey said oh [__] I just
realized who the show is about
technically he filmed the first moving
picture that indeed he did uh even
though I and now I kind of wonder if
anybody has kids that are school age
like are they still teaching them that
Thomas Edison invented all that [__]
like the movie camera and stuff because
he absolutely did not no
he had a company that just [__]
absorbed everybody and made them [__]
discover [__]
some of them some of the [__] he just
[__] bought or stole yeah he had a
good legal team he did and he had a
thing too where he was like real good at
manipulating um you know patent law like
I said that he could
you know and he had money and resources
and stuff so he could always kind of
like oh if this person had a good idea
that he wanted to like you know swipe
then he could kind of like file his own
patent or be like oh well this patent is
for this little slightly different thing
and it's not like yours and then he
could just like bury the dude he did
that kind of [__] yeah like that he
didn't I don't even know if he did
anything technically illegal but it was
for sure like unethical like a lot of
stuff that he did
yeah but like I said I don't know if
Thomas Edison was involved in this case
or not yeah I killed somebody but a lot
of yeah and I really wouldn't have been
his style to kill somebody I don't think
it wasn't a pattern to that well he
might have like had it done possible but
there wasn't a pattern of it that's true
usually there's a pattern if a person
did it once they do it more than once
and there's a pattern yeah yeah usually
but then again that's the usual the
usual culprits are political people not
so much corporate so although I bet you
a lot of corporate [__] happened and
it's just that nobody was notable in
history so their deaths were not really
recorded or noticed right in politics
you'd notice it
Ben said it was standard business
practice at the time to crush your
opposition with lawyers and gangsters
pretty much yeah pretty much yeah yeah
that was the game back then so I kind of
feel like it's not
it's not far-fetched that Thomas Edison
had something done
um but I don't know if that's true but
it wouldn't if I found out that it was
true I don't think anyone's gonna know
now it is because it's been such a long
time but it's like I absolutely would
not be shocked at all like just to know
that he'd like
um yeah Ben said of course Edison didn't
kill anyone he had people on the payroll
for that yeah he wouldn't do it himself
he definitely wouldn't have done that
I'm just thinking if he'd had somebody
killed he would have done it more than
once and I think it would have been well
maybe there was and maybe he was just
that good and we he got because he was a
smart dude I mean nobody's saying that
so if he got people killed
he was a ruthless businessman
I'm not going to put murder on him you
know I'm working for hire we but he was
ruthless I'm not well he's dead now
what's he gonna do sue me yeah his ghost
is Gonna Come at me and then sue me
we're gonna see I'm getting sued by
Thomas Edison's ghost
the evidence the genius or or other
supposed evidence that Jenny's dug up
yeah you know maybe if I hear the story
maybe I might change my mind you might
be yeah I mean this was like I said this
was a long time ago so it's kind of hard
to like dig stuff up there was a couple
other videos about this on the internet
which are really good on YouTube rather
that are um actually really good
but I think even BuzzFeed unsolved did
this one but there's not a ton there was
only like three or four really good ones
Edison was also bad about stamping down
on [__] any kind of disruptive
Technologies too like yeah he pretty
much destroyed Tesla yeah Tesla was
going to make electricity and just kind
of make it free you could broadcast it
yeah and [__] Edison wasn't going to
have that you couldn't put a meter on
that yeah he had no patience for people
that invented things that they thought
would be a public good because another
guy I can't remember who it was but
another guy that invented something uh
really awesome was actually just gonna
he didn't bother getting a patent on it
because he said oh this is a public good
and I should just like release it and he
was like oh no and he filed a patent on
it and so the dude like died broke yeah
so yeah he would do [__] like that which
not cool Edison you didn't file a patent
well I'm gonna file pad yeah there you
go I invented that [__] can't do it I'm
gonna take all your money yeah and
you're gonna die in a gutter somewhere
yeah what a [__] it's like it's I
mean it's he's just kind of like I don't
know that that's just dude didn't have
game he should have realized that that
would have happened that he'd had the
patent but then he'd just give license
out for free that's what he should have
done
because somebody else could just block
him by getting the packing patent you
know yeah and I mean I think patent law
was a lot different back then too like
you could kind of you couldn't infringe
on Patton and during that time a lot of
Technologies were new
so anything that you made you're
infringing on somebody's patent
somewhere in your invention
it was real rough the Firearms were like
that like they everybody knew how to
make an automatic pistol the problem was
is that Browning had that patent the
swing Lake patent had a lot of the
[__] delayed recoil patents so you
had to find up a new way to make an
automatic pistol well there are only a
couple different there's only like two
really good ways right you know so
anything that is not those two good ways
there it's a it's a it's it's not a good
way it'll still work but mechanically no
it's not efficient so they're just
trying to and they did it just to evade
patents
and it really it held back [__]
firearm technology for decades working
out all these [__] pens now it's all
lapsed you can make anything now
without worrying about pads and you know
everything's been done and everything's
been patented and all the patents have
expired so you can you can do anything
now
well all of that stuff yeah because yeah
because after a while like your pad is
only good for like so long yeah well
most of the [__] most of the ideas were
patented like in the 1910s
so they're long all they're long right
and [__] lapsed because they had
enough engineering skills to understand
all the different ways you can make that
machine or a machine gun
and they were fighting over little
things like feed Pauls things you know
which is just something that pulls in a
bell you know stupid [__]
the magazines that are in the butt of
the pistol that kind of stuff
a button that you can press to drop a
magazine that [__] was patented for a
while right you know well yeah because
anything like that that would give you
an advantage or like making some money
that no one else could use right so
you'd see some crazy [__] in the early
1900s where it was like uh one fantastic
High
-tech feature and and the high-tech look
to the gun but everything else was
[__] like antique and crazy and
backwards because they couldn't do it
because the patent infringements you
know they were trying to find new ways
so I had a lot of French pistols look so
crazy
this fabric National was involved
they didn't have patents for things or
did have patents for things and they
just came up some crazy looking [__] but
it all worked out eventually the patents
expired on everything I mean I you know
obviously I think the people the person
that invented something should get the
credit for it and should get the bulk of
the money for it
um but that doesn't always happen
because of various uh legal loopholes
and
things like that which is kind of and
that's kind of what ended up happening
to Louis Prince like I said Ben said it
was corn flakes all over again right
yeah that was like a whole thing we
needed did we ever do a show about that
didn't we do a show about the Kellogg
Brothers no I never did I thought I
thought we did but maybe we did a long
long I think it was like a long time ago
but yeah there was a there was a great
like story about that
on uh the food that built America I
think was like the first season of the
second season about the whole like
invention of corn flakes and stuff it's
a fascinating [__] story maybe we did
a show about it because I kind of feel
like we did a show about Kellogg with
about the health spa and all that kind
of stuff I don't know I'm like I'm
pretty familiar with that story so I
can't remember if we did a show or not
and then Ben said yeah but it was up to
the patent holder to sue the infringer
in court and if they weren't rich and
influential they were at a huge
disadvantage well that's always the case
no matter what I mean if you're poor you
might as well just March yourself off to
jail because that's where you're going
the Colton FN [__] had all the good
pads for a long time so then they had
all the money so they would sue you
they would yeah
it's just kind of like you know but back
in the day I don't know if they still do
this but I remember hearing back in the
80s how like some little Podunk daycare
somewhere would like paint some Disney
characters on the side of the year that
Disney would come and sue them yeah so
they were like [__] we're gonna paint
Fred flitz down on the side then Hannah
Barbera won't Sue evidently all the old
Disney characters are going to be forced
out into [__] public domain soon
they've been re-upping the the uh the
patents yeah I don't but evidently
they're saying that's not legal they
said it's not long I'd be interested to
talk to like a copyright type lawyer
because copyright law and I know this is
going to sound weird but copyright law
is like actually really interesting to
me and I'm always just kind of like
because I know that after you know like
a book or something like that is what
the life of the author plus a hundred
years or something like that but there
are some different loopholes I think
like where the surviving you know like
say you know Bram Stoker's Widow who
kind of sued the makers of nospora too
because you know they infringe on his
patent because the story wasn't that old
but you can kind of like re you can kind
of re-up the copyright but I don't know
what the parameters are of that because
I kind of I kind of felt like that after
a century had passed or something like
that I don't know if you can actually
just keep doing that like in perpetuity
that seems like it would be I heard that
Mickey Mouse Donald Duck and all those
things should be they should be a public
domain by now
because they're old enough and they're
they're doing something kind of sideways
to keep to keep the patents on them but
sometimes when you're talking about
publishing type stuff and dealing with
Star Trek Star Wars or anything you know
they what matters in the patent is how
it was drawn
so maybe like the real old versions of
Mickey would be in public like Steamboat
Willie yeah
but some of the newer drawings of him
which might still be protected until
they lapse too so
Disney could
keep its identity by saying oh yeah yeah
that's the old Mickey this is the real
Mickey this is the new Mickey the arm
this is our Mickey okay this is real
Mickey because some of them be a
different drawing up because some of
those old Disney characters looked
completely different than they look
nowadays they didn't look that good they
did it well like I said it was like old
animation you know what I mean like
Steamboat Willie when the [__] did that
come out 19.
20 something maybe it was earlier than
that it was over 100 years but yeah it
was like it's pretty [__] up looking
but everything looked [__] up back
then yeah you know all the cartoons and
everything they didn't they didn't I
liked them anyway when I was kid I did
too yeah but I remember
um Alice the group I remember seeing uh
because I was more familiar with kind of
like the 60s 70s or maybe like 50s 60s
like Porky Pig cartoons and then like
sometimes every now and then they would
show like one of the really old Porky
Pig cartoons and Porky Pig looked a lot
they made him a lot cuter like later on
he was just like a cute he's kind of
chubby you know what I mean like Porky
Pig but back in like the old days he
looked like a big disgusting fat pig
yeah you know what I mean and I was like
he's like a man he didn't look a child
yeah it wasn't so they made him like a
lot cuter which I kind of liked because
I was like I don't know if I really like
that like old character that doesn't
look too appealing you know what I mean
yeah uh Tammy's Here Deborah Hockett hey
guys just got off work made it uh curly
overheiser says YouTube notifications
are horrible I didn't know you were
alive yeah we always do a a live show on
Wednesday night and most other and
Monday night too
uh Ben said there was a kid's headstone
in a cemetery that had Spider-Man on it
a year or two ago and Marvel demanded to
remove the image that's [__]
ridiculous Ben said a lot of Pop Culture
things are coming out of copyrights such
as Superman but it's the 1930s version
without heat vision Kryptonite Etc
that's still copyrighted well I mean
that makes sense
yeah Ben said Winnie the Pooh and Peter
Pan are free and clear for anyone to use
now yeah that's why they just made a
horror movie with Winnie the Pooh like
what the [__] with that thing called
I've heard it wasn't very good but I
kind of want to see it anyway but yeah
that's why because uh Winnie the Pooh
was like yeah
so uh yeah you can't use the images
previously used in books movies still
under copyright yeah but I kind of feel
like if you went well if you went back
to the original
Winnie the Pooh books I mean those are
more than 100 years old Blood and Honey
yeah that's what it's called you see I I
would [__] game that system though
what I would do is I'd make a restaurant
where the 1920s or a 1930s Black and
White theme inside the the decor and
everything and it would be like the old
[__] Steamboat Willie
that would be cool I would go there yeah
so what you do is you you you it's
Mickey Mouse but it's back in time and
if you and that would work out that'd be
great you can make it look you could do
like a whole like old school like
animation yeah that'd be pretty neat yep
and make it make it all black and white
black and white inside too yeah that's
what I'm saying that would be really
really cool if you're in a black and
white movie yeah oh that would be really
cool
they should they should do that I kind
of like the idea of like theme
stuff like that like just weird themes
yeah
I've heard that they've started doing I
don't think there's any restaurants to
do this but I've heard that they've
started doing Titanic dinner parties you
know what I mean like they feed like
because they know what the menu was like
on the Titanic like so they're like give
you that food and kind of make it like
it to like you're on the Titanic I'm
like I don't know if I want to pretend
like I'm on the Titanic we all know how
that happened I don't know if I'm
looking into old-fashioned food
yeah it's that's the thing like I kind
of looked at the menu and I'm like I
don't know that doesn't really sound all
that good A lot of it I'm like what even
is that it's like the 1920s you know it
was 100 years ago I don't know I didn't
use spice
they thought black pepper was some [__]
but what's hot
[Laughter]
no more black pepper please
they're funny but uh yeah or like
paprika or something like that which
like doesn't he but like paprika doesn't
even like register to be honest
uh Crowley said my friend went to go see
it that's bloody honey the the horror
Winnie the Pooh movie he liked it
because it was so bad yeah I kind of
like I've I just had the general
impression that a lot of because I
haven't you know because eventually I'll
probably watch it but I've just seen
like the the Expressions on the faces of
some of the channels that I watch like
on the thumbnails and the summer were
like what the [__] you know what I mean
so I'm just like okay
Zach said oh [__] I forgot what's up
y'all well you didn't forget because
you're here you know and it's only like
20 minutes in so you didn't miss much of
anything you didn't miss much of
anything we haven't really got into this
into the subject yeah not really I mean
we were kind of talking about Thomas
Edison a little bit we were talking
about patent law a little bit which all
is kind of like relevant to
uh to this topic and Zach might be
interested in some of the stuff because
it's kind of it's film history you know
what I mean
so I guess we'll get into the story like
I said it's not super super long it's
not super super complicated so you know
I guess we'll just kind of get into it
and we'll do some discussion as we go on
so yeah I kind of feel like I don't know
about nowadays but I remember learning
in school that the inventor of many
things uh but in up to and including the
movie camera uh was Thomas Edison
um you know with maybe an assist from
you know the Lumiere Brothers somebody
like that now the thing about this time
period and I'm talking like late 19th
century
is that there were a lot of inventors
it was very much in the air
um trying to figure out like the best
way to do like a moving picture camera
because they had it already invented
kind of like optical illusion sort of
toys you know what I mean like they'd
have those paper wheels with like
pictures on like a Flickr book type of
toy so they knew the principal behind if
you take a bunch of pictures in sequence
and flip them through really fast it
looks like they're moving but they
hadn't really been able to figure out
exactly a way to film a moving image and
like project it you know what I'm saying
um so we have people like Edward
mybridge who did very famously did the
um the horse Galloping thing yeah you
know what I mean where that's how they
found out that like the horse had all
four feet off the ground at the same
time and stuff like that so they kind of
knew
they knew the principal behind it and
they were looking for the best way to
make a moving picture camera
now
so I kind of feel like Thomas Edison
usually gets credited for inventing the
moving picture
however
um it's pretty I don't know how well
known it is nowadays but they're pretty
sure with 99.99 uh certainty that Louis
the pr Louis laprince was actually the
first man to make a motion picture with
a motion picture camera it was only a
few seconds long they still have it it
still exists uh you can see it on
YouTube it's about a second two seconds
something like that and it's just like
his family like kind of just Milling
around in the yard like it is at his
in-laws house or something like that
because you know it was a big deal back
then it's a movie that was like the
first one
and he made a couple he actually made
one of his son uh Adolf who was playing
an accordion and he made one that was a
few seconds long like off a bridge in
Leeds in England so I mean the like I
said those films still exist and they
know that he made them much uh like very
very much earlier than Thomas Edison in
his whole thing
so nowadays Louis laprince in film
circles is generally known as the father
Cinema or the father of cinematography
because he is the first known person to
have made a movie or what they would
call a movie
so let's talk a little bit about
his background
so he was born in France in a place
called Mets in 1841 and he actually came
from a military family uh his dad was a
major of artillery
now interestingly one of his dad's
friends was the very famous Louis
daguerre who invented the daguerreotype
which is the very very early form of
Photography it was prior to them like um
you know doing photos or you know making
photos on paper like having light
sensitive paper they used to do them on
like it was like a silver plate or
copper plate or silver copper
combination or something like that so
that's what that was like he so he
invented that the daguerreotype so when
he was a kid when Louis Le Prince was a
kid and was hanging out with Louis De
Guerre who was his father's friend he
got really interested in photography and
it would become something of a hobby
like as the time went on
so later on as he got a little bit older
he actually went uh to Paris and studied
art there and then he went to Leipzig in
Germany and studied chemistry so
obviously those two things would kind of
feed into his love of Photography and
movie making later on
so uh he's French as I am as I mentioned
in 1866 he actually moved to England
uh he had a friend named John Whitley
and John Whitley had a brass Foundry so
uh Louis laprince went there to work for
him
and he ended up marrying uh Whitley's
sister Elizabeth who was also an artist
now the two of them they actually opened
up like an applied arts school and one
thing that they figured out how to do
was how to take
photographs and like put them on
metal or on ceramic or something like
that so they started making like
commemorative plates like that wasn't
really a thing that happened at like
people painted on them and [__] but they
figured out a way how to make like put a
photograph on like glass or ceramic or
something like that so they started
selling all of these commemorative
plates like with Queen Victoria and [__]
like that on them and um you know the
Prime Minister whoever that was at the
time and so they actually got quite
successful because I think they were
kind of the first ones to do that to
kind of have this shop where
you know they were putting photographs
on household items which was kind of
like a new thing
now in 1881
Louis went to the United States
um under the auspices of like you know
working for his partner or whatever
now he actually ended up becoming a
manager for this kind of artist group
that would do these like Panorama type
things that you know just exhibits that
they would do around the country
now while he was kind of going around
he'd been interested in photography for
a while like I said but he was also like
a lot of other inventors were at the
time like starting to get interested in
moving pictures like how like what was
the best way to go about that
so
what he decided to do at first now they
still have his first camera that he
invented that he actually patented in
Europe
and it's this kind of big square like
wooden box
and it had
16 lenses
because he worked out that
to make a movie look like I mean they
didn't call it a movie then but to make
it look like like from a flicker book
point of view to make it look like
natural movement instead of like a
flicker book you needed 16 frames per
second he determined
so he's like well
if I put 16 lenses in the camera and it
shoots like 16 photographs like in six
very quick succession and then you put
those together like and actually the um
the thing that he had in there was like
paper the film was paper so that was the
first you know thing that he made
now there were a couple of problems with
this and maybe if you know anything
about photography you probably have
figured out what they were
because this had 16 lenses
um it took pictures in quick succession
all right but all of the pictures were
from a slightly different position so
when you put them all together it looked
okay but it looked a little bit janky
because it was kind of like because it
was kind of like that because the
pictures didn't line up you know what I
mean
so he wasn't super happy with that
um so he's like well there has got to be
a better way there he is to do that well
yeah move well that's what well yeah
that's what he eventually like hit upon
but that was just like his first like I
said he did have a patent on that one
like the 16 and they still have the um
the Prototype it's in I think it's in a
museum in England you gotta kind of fail
first before you can succeed just like
anything else you know so [__]
he got the very Basics done yeah 16
frames and I mean it did work yeah but
then it it unveiled another problem so
he goes so he knows now he's got to move
in a different direction you gotta you
gotta use one lens yeah that's what that
tells you you got to take 16 pictures
with one lens how do you do that
you gotta have a [__] moving film got
to move you got to have a flickering
shutter that's opening and closing you
got to figure out how to do that yeah
mechanically uh he did he did actually
figure out how to do that yeah he did
eventually figure out how to do it
um it took him a few years like you know
because this is over because you know
when he first moved to
um he first went to the US in 1881 and
he actually didn't
go back to England I don't think until
1887 and by that time he had kind of
solved a lot of the problems you know
engendered by the 16 lens camera and it
figured out how to compile it just down
to one lens now I think I'm not entirely
sure I've because I've watched a bunch
of different documentaries about this
and like read a bunch of different
things
I think because some of the sources said
that he also figured out because
remember how I said in the 16 lens
camera he was using paper film yeah and
I think prior to that they'd use like a
like a gelatin type thing I think he was
the first one to come up with Celluloid
I could be wrong about that
um but he determined that that was going
to be the best way to do it it was clear
yeah yeah so probably I could be wrong
but I think that he's this was 1887 18th
right away that would have been high
tech but yeah which maybe they used
something like that in in rapping
plastic wrapping around a box maybe
yeah I'm not sure I mean you know
Celluloid obviously has a lot of
industrial applications but I'm not
really sure what they were using it for
at that point in time they were using it
for something he knew about it yeah it
was some kind of clear paper that he
knew about probably somebody was using
it to wrap food
yeah and then put the food inside of a
box and sell it sounds like some food
industry would try to do
or maybe put plastic wrapping on the
outside of a box and it probably wasn't
good enough it's probably like Saran
Wrap
so you're gonna have to change it so you
can feed it through a mechanical camera
and impregnate it with chemicals so you
can get exposure you can expose an image
on it so there's going to be a lot of a
lot of a lot a lot of challenges
but they're probably they would they
must have been doing dealing with some
kind of clear plastic paper
yeah that's kind of known about it right
that's what I mean I think that like he
was maybe the first one to figure that
out that that would be the best
application for that because you could
shine a light through it and project off
of it right all right well and that was
his thing I mean he really wanted it he
he envisioned it like showing it like at
like a movie theater like you would
nowadays like that's what he wanted to
he was right ultimately do with it he
was right you can do it
but you know the thing about like the
chemicals and everything like that like
that was kind of the easy part because
they like I said they could already they
already had still photography and
everybody said well this is essentially
like still photography but a bunch of
still photographs just played really
fast so it looks like you know to your
eye that it's moving and so that like
all of the same uh principles applied
they just had to figure out the
mechanics of how to take that many
pictures quickly and how to project them
and things like that so that's what he
was working on
so finally he figures out he goes back
to England uh his he had a workshop in
Leeds and figured out the single lens
camera and again this looked kind of
just like a big wooden box or whatever
and it actually could photograph between
12 to 20 frames per second so like right
around the 16 frame that's what he
wanted
now uh so as I mentioned before the
first movie that he made which was just
his you know in-laws or his family
members and stuff just kind of wandering
around in the yard because he's like
just move around it's a moving picture
it's a new thing which is like really
funny
um he actually took that on October the
14th
1888. so that was uh the actually like I
said is in-laws house like and they so
they were all just like out in the
garden
so he shot the first film with that like
I said you can see it on YouTube
um it still exists which is actually
kind of awesome because you know 1888
that was a long time ago that was like
when [__] Jack the Ripper was running
around damn isn't that crazy yeah that
said but he was Jack the Rippers running
around England and meanwhile Louis the
prince is over there just like hey walk
around so I can film you with my
newfangled device that's like kind of
funny to think about actually but uh
that those two things were like
happening at around the same time
but yeah uh so like I said it's only a
few seconds long but come on I mean
nobody had ever done it before so give
the guy a break
so he also as I mentioned made a couple
other films uh one of them he was just
standing on a bridge and you know it's
called traffic Crossing Leeds Bridge
it's not Cars traffic obviously but you
know just the horses and people and [__]
like that and he did one of his uh Sun
playing an accordion
so uh once he had it how he wanted it
he's like okay that looks pretty cool
now I want to figure out how to project
it because that was
the end goal he wanted to like show it
he he had in mind not so much
entertainment style movies he had more
like kind of an education type of thing
which I guess a lot of them did back
then because nobody really knew
I don't know I guess nobody really
thought about it back then like maybe
filming a play or something like that
but he mostly wanted it for like
educational purposes but he's like I
want to be able to like project you know
moving pictures and like show people
other parts of the world and things like
that they might not be able to see and
like show it to Big audiences like all
at once well this is high-tech [__] so
he's thinking it's gonna be used for
science that's what I'm saying yeah all
the money you could make show in a movie
he had that hadn't covered and probably
like in probably like a couple years
later people's like we can make porn
with that yeah yeah we'll bring these
literal jerks in here and make some
[__] pain [__] you know we have
somebody else come clean up the machine
but yeah
so um as I mentioned he did have a
patent on the camera
um but when he was he was working on the
projector and he was actually gonna get
a patent for that as well
now apparently according to his family
at least
he had a working projector
and he had put his movies into the
projector and projected them on the wall
like of his Workshop in leads
unfortunately
um there's like no proof of that
and
spoiler alert he disappeared before uh
anything could come of it which is
really kind of a shame but according to
all his family they said yeah he brought
us in there and we watched this he
projected it it was successful like it
worked
so in 1890
Louis decides he's going to move back to
the United States permanently
and he's going to like kind of tour
around the country and have like public
demonstrations of his projector you know
his film projector
um which you know you'll note Edison and
The Lumiere Brothers both did that much
much later than this but this is what
Louis Prince was planning to do
so um his wife and kids actually went
out ahead of him they had bought a
mansion in New York and it was all they
were all waiting there and he was
supposed to come out and meet them
so Louis uh packs up all his stuff which
was probably like a a [__] back then
man everything I complained about [__]
taking forever nowadays holy [__] man
it's like everything must have taken
forever to do back then [__] horse
and carriage you had to like pack all
this stuff or anything like a train or
you had to take a ship and it was like a
[__] week or some [__] like that [__]
that
but yeah so he packs up all his stuff
now before he was gonna go to the us
though like before he was gonna get on
the ship he was actually gonna make a
stop in Dijon France which is where his
brother Albert lived
now he was visiting Albert because
um nothing to do with uh with the patent
stuff because he had all of his patent
paperwork and he had all of the devices
and he had all his prototypes and he had
everything with him because he was like
as soon as he got to the U.S he was
going to file the patents and work it
all out
but he was going to visit Albert because
their mother had died recently
and had left Louis and Albert
um her she had like a fancy townhouse in
Paris that was apparently like worth a
lot of money I guess and they were gonna
split it or they were gonna kind of like
sort out what they were gonna you know
do with it or whatever so he stopped by
to see Albert for a couple of days and
then he was going to you know get on the
train and then go and get on the ship
and then go to the United States
so on September 16th 1890
he went with his brother Albert to the
train station in Dijon where he was
going to catch the Express Train to
Paris
and then go on to uh you know to get the
ship
to go across the Atlantic
however
when the train arrived in Paris
Louis laprince was not on it and neither
was any of his stuff
um I will note that the train was in
Express from Dijon to Paris and did not
make any stops in between
I will also note that nobody on the
train afterwards
um had noticed him on the train even
though by all accounts he probably would
have stood out because he was six foot
four or something like that which was
quite tall for the time that doesn't
mean that people had noticed him or had
like would have noticed him necessarily
but it seems odd that nobody remembered
him
so they don't actually know I mean
Albert his brother he was the one that
said yeah he got on the train
and you know I wave goodbye and
everything like that and then he just
vanished off the face of the Earth and
neither hide nor hair of him has been
found to this day they have found
nothing they found out of his luggage
they found absolutely no trace of him
whatsoever
uh so yeah he did get on the plane
though on the train well see okay we'll
get into that a little bit because
according to his brother he did
but we'll get into that
okay
uh so yeah all now all of the luggage
that he had when he got on the train
that had all of his like I said it had
all of his stuff and it had the
projector it had all of his inventions
it had all of his patent stuff all of
his papers that he had filed and all of
that kind of stuff had everything
because he was moving to the United
States he was taking all that stuff with
him so he had a bunch of stuff yeah yeah
uh that means he it was removed
yeah they didn't find anything
yeah that's fishy so well that's why
people are still talking about this
story nowadays because it's very fishy
so yeah you never arrived no no they
never arrived he never found they never
found anything he was intercepted
because his friends were waiting for him
like at the Paris train station and he
never showed up now they didn't think
they weren't alarmed at first because
they said oh well maybe he missed the
train or maybe he decided to take a
later one
um you know and got her something so
they weren't like all that alarmed but
then like as time went on and he never
showed up then obviously you know the
family and friends like went into you
know panic mode and likes did an
extensive investigationally reported the
police and it was kind of a pain in the
ass because you know he lived in England
but then he was in France and he was
going to the United States so they had
to keep going back and forth from like
the English police to the French police
and like trying to figure out what's
going on
um but they never I mean there was
literally nothing of him that was found
nothing at all
which is crazy but I'm already imagining
what you could have done but go ahead
yeah I mean yeah and we'll get it okay
so like I said that's pretty much it
it's just kind of like he got on the
train
and he never arrived we were gonna
intercept this guy
take him out and take all this stuff you
know you're gonna have to have a bunch
of bags
his possessions taken off the train you
know you know that has to happen
and it has to happen before the train
reaches his destination
so if you're going to take a bunch of
these cases or suitcases and packages
off
you can add another package to that big
load and no one would know the
difference
and that extra package could have his
body in it yeah that's that's how you
would do it
kill him on the train using your team
and then pack him into a box
and get that box in into the luggage car
some and then have them all come off at
a different destination not at the end
at a destination that he was not going
to go to in other words where his family
is picking him up
then all that stuff comes off you
probably just use the regular Porters
that do it
but then you have to collect them as if
they're yours so you have to change the
paperwork on them to make it like it's a
delivery
or the person in charge of the operation
becomes the new owner and he pretends
that that's his [__] and he has to take
it off with his assistance so that means
this has to be done with the with the
aid of the railroads the only way
well I'll note that like I said he got
on the train in Dijon and he was
supposed to get off in Paris but there
were no stops in between it was an
Express train okay but it kept on going
right I assume yeah because they usually
it was unloaded after
later
it's unloaded at a different one
it didn't he didn't have to come off
there before he was down the cargo hold
in a box
with all the other boxes
that's how I would do it see this is why
like trained murder is always kind of
like fascinate me
I don't think you could do this without
help
you'd have to have knowledge of all the
uh
uh the train could operations and the
paperwork that they use and have either
fake papers made for the luggage like
the luggage tags
copies or stolen real ones
because you have to re-tag all that
luggage
and then you have a ticket already that
you brought that you bought and then you
made up that luggage with your ticket
once you're in the trade
and then when you get to your
destination you have all that stuff
unloaded the people unloading it are not
the same people that loaded it they
don't they don't know anything
yeah that's true but I think
you'd have to have a good knowledge of
the trade in other words somebody on
your team would have had to have been an
ex-employee or active employee
to help you to do that
you know what I mean yeah because you
have to know
what's the tickets look like where do
the tickets come from can you get to the
tickets
can you what's the codes that have to be
on there to get it to come off at the
destination you want it to come off at
how do you change your ticket to say
that those that those um that that
luggage belongs to you it's something
like that they they know the trained
system
real well
it probably had help
okay that's awesome Hugo said there's a
Frankenstein movie made in 1910 by
Edison yeah I've seen it uh I wonder who
really made it yeah
um it's not very good I mean it's okay
it's an okay adaptation the monster
looks a little
silly but I did like a big long
um like silent movie watch along thing
like on my uh blog where I just kind of
watched it and wrote about it like I was
watching it but uh I found it
entertaining but yeah
um Ben said brother Albert murdered him
loaded his stuff onto the train and
maybe pretended to be him at the ticket
office did anyone check his ticket on
the train see I'm assuming that nobody
did because they interviewed as far as I
know everybody that had been on the
train or everybody that had worked on
the train reporters and nobody had seen
him or nobody could remember seeing him
that doesn't mean he wasn't there I'm
just saying that nobody remembered him
in particular so most of the theories
kind of swirl around maybe he never got
on the train at all or didn't get on the
train alive
maybe he was killed in the train station
and put in one of the boxes along with
the other stuff that was going to go on
the train you know what I mean and then
you assume his identity and you have him
loaded into into your train into your
luggage hold as if he was your luggage
and you were the guy who killed him
you're assumed his identity that may
have been that
yeah possibly because it'd be easier to
kill him in the train station
I would think yeah
he'd have
he asked him you know he trusts you or
something he you asked him to go
somewhere with you and then you [__]
clobber him shoot him with a suppressed
pistol something like that they had
stuff like that back then
well yeah and then they offed each other
all the time yeah and then you put him
in put him in the luggage because it was
much easier to get away with it yeah and
then you wheel them out wheel him out
there in the luggage I mean check him in
like cargo
then you got his ticket
Ben said it would have been easiest to
kill him by Dynamite in the train yeah
yeah it's a little Overkill though
acceptable losses she's obviously a
covert operation this is James Bond [__]
nobody's nobody's supposed to know this
even happened and then it vanished from
the face of History so it was a covert
operation I mean it definitely does seem
like yeah
so okay so those are the facts of the
case now these are the theories about
what may have happened to Louis laprint
first Theory
he committed suicide
I don't buy this one I'm not saying it's
impossible because you know everybody
you never know well that's kind of a
problem with a lot of these theories is
they never did find his body
um you know proponents of this say well
maybe he never even got on the train
maybe he just like jumped in a river
somewhere
um you know maybe he did get on the
train but he jumped off uh something
like that but on the other hand it's
like one he wasn't like most of the I
kind of feel like most of the people who
because there have been a couple books
written about this
most of the people who put forward the
suicide Theory are like oh you know
maybe he was going bankrupt or maybe
there was like some evidence that maybe
he didn't have as much money as blah
blah but honestly like everything else
that I saw said that he was actually
pretty financially successful and even
if he wasn't that financially successful
he knew that he had a [__] movie
camera he knew what that was I mean he
knew what the applications for it would
be he knew that he would probably be
made very wealthy
by having that and by like taking it and
touring it around so I don't think he
necessarily would have
checked out right before like right on
the cusp of I'm going to the United
States and I'm going to show my new
machine and I'm going to get a patent
and I'm going to make all this money on
it well no he was getting okay he had a
patent on the other one on the other
machine the first one
when did the patent for this appear in
the U.S how much long how much longer
well guess who guess who did it Edison
right right yeah yeah and how much how
much longer after after he disappeared
yeah
um not all that long well like I said
that's why I like a lot of people think
that Edison had something to do with
this [__] but I don't know I don't know
or somebody who realized that they could
make money with Edison maybe well yeah
yeah I mean because Edison he wasn't
just Edison he had a lot of people like
working working right
so you know we had a whole bunch of guys
that would looking for looking for guys
that they could steal inventions from
and sell them sell them to Edison they
probably had he probably had a whole
system of spies worked industrial spies
worked out Edison I think he did yeah
so it was one of his industrial spies
maybe he tracked this guy down in France
and knock him off and steal his [__]
before he put before he posts the U.S
patent and then later you take his
machine and his ideas you have other
guys look at it and then you come up
with a better patent and you put put
that in there yeah because he patented
his kinetoscope in oh [__] now I can't
remember what year it was but it was
like it wasn't long after he disappeared
so it was like 1891 or something like
sometimes you get a second third or
fourth set of eyeballs on something
they'll make it even better and they'll
say well [__] patenting that machine
this machine's taught us to make a
better patent we'll do that
you know it might have been that because
you also don't want to show up with a
[__] patent for for a carbon copy his
machine that makes it a suspect
well see the thing about it though and
I'm gonna I'm not excusing Edison but I
am saying that it was it is a fact that
a lot of inventors were working on a
motion picture camera at this time
because because of Edward my bridge and
because of you know all of these optical
illusion toys it was something that was
very much that everybody was kind of
like trying to work on it so it's
possible that you could have come up
with something very similar to what he
came up with just by coincidence well
it's just like in the Firearms field but
but when Edison is involved I get a
little bit
about it because he's very very well
known for like ripping off other people
videos and taking credit for him in this
period also it was the same with
firearms
yeah new patents would come out amazing
new Firearms would come out but guys
we're working on ideas like that firearm
all many many teams happening at the
same time this that went on for a long
time even in the late even in the 30s
and 40s guys coming up with prototypes
that are kind of like assault rifles
um
so yeah there's
I guess you could say there's a
convergent evolution but that's because
all the designers are talking about this
concept so it wouldn't be one dude
talking about motion picture camera it'd
be like 30 or 40 of them talking about
motion picture cameras all of them
trying to guard their own secrets and
[__] yeah so it would be like that
like I said it's they're going to kind
of come up with the same thing though
yeah the people are going to come out
kind of feel the same thing it happens
all the time there's only a couple ways
you can do that make a camera yeah
mechanically like that right
so the most important thing is how do
you drive it do you have to crank it or
do you wind up a spring like a big you
know what I mean and and it times itself
because see cranking it depends on your
consistency in cranking it you know what
I mean if if you speed up accidentally
you'll [__] up the image
they didn't really have it they had
electric motors but they wouldn't have
had the batteries and the power it would
have been big and heavy so you couldn't
have a battery powered electric motor
camera at this point it would have been
something with a wind-up spring or or a
crank
at this point
but like I said that's where the pads
would differ some guy's patents might be
you know you sit there you turn a key
and wind it up and you got 30 seconds of
filming with a nice consistent
image you know it's spinning like a
Clockwork
on time
so they've been about there would have
been a bunch of different versions of it
Edison probably would have had his
fingers in all of them any of them that
he could find yeah he knew all about
what was going on he really did keep his
finger on the boat on everything right
because he you know he's like hey who's
whose ideas can I steal today which are
the best ones he would he was kind of
guy that would buy everything so no one
else could get it yeah it was just the
way it is yeah which that was the smart
way to do it well it certainly made him
a lot of money uh [__] over everybody
else but you know
I guess
that's like [__] everybody I got mine I
guess that's that well there's something
to be said for guys like Edison in a big
big Rich guys they had
the money and the infrastructure to make
these ideas a reality
they could get that [__] done and
mass-produce it
so technology moved quickly in the
industrial revolution that was one good
thing about it if it was scattered out
between all these little Artisan
creators
the Relentless March of industrial and
Technology would industrial technology
would have
its Evolution would have been slowed
down
so it was a rough period to live in but
we reaped the rewards for it without
them it probably would have taken
another 100 years
imagine if it was you know
1920s still you know that's what it
would be like well we wouldn't know any
difference we wouldn't know any
difference
it would just be like it is you know
what I mean it's just like you wouldn't
know any difference like oh man it could
have been like really cool we could have
had cell phones and Netflix and all this
other kind of [__] a lot of [__] there
was a lot of [__] that almost came out
in the 1930s
but the war stopped it the the the the
world wars stopped a lot of [__]
one of the things that was going to come
out in the 30s was television yeah they
know how to do it yeah we were watching
something about that not too long ago
but then the war broke out they were
like they made all that [__] top secret
and they said we'll do this after the
war
uh and then in the meantime television
cameras became like top secret weapons
technology
they were using video cameras to
remotely pilot
I think they were [__] Liberator
bombers loaded full of explosives that
they would use as a big cruise missile
and
ditch it or they would fly it right into
a German weapon system and blow it up
we're trying to blow up German super
weapons with it
that damn
rocket mortar that they were building
and now what was his name one of the
candidates got killed
flying that thing because you you needed
somebody on board I think it was JFK's
brother
he was in the war
yeah you had to have somebody pilot it
to take it to take off
then once it was in air you armed the
bombs and then you jumped out it came
out on a parachute then the guys back at
base were looking through cameras and
flying the airplane remotely through
cameras
well JFK he took he got it up in the air
went to his jump off point because this
is it okay he went to go switch the to
arm the bomb the things just blew up it
was vaporized there's tons of ammunition
went up
uh somebody wired it wrong
[__] happens
[Laughter]
I mean you know that was a top top
secret mission and it was funny that
the Kennedys were involved were were
involved in it
Dave is here hey YouTube just pooping in
to say hello
he's pooping in to say hello Ben says uh
Hedy Lamarr invented a wireless remote
system for submarine Torpedoes yes
that's true she did and I actually
wanted uh I've been want to do a show on
her for a while too because I think Zach
was uh recommended that I was like yeah
that would actually be a good show as
well Sebastian says Germany had TVs well
some people I mean
and then Zach said during the Great
Depression era there were a few films
that were actually shot in widescreen on
70 millimeter film but it was expensive
so they stopped doing it until the 1950s
that's another thing too is that a lot
of times I think the technology for
something exists but I guess sometimes
it's just like too cost prohibitive to
like to use it until there's like you
know until it gets cheaper the Germans
were also working on a space plane that
was like this kind of like a space
shuttle
it was called the Sanger antipodal
bomber
and you launched it was a big rocket
sled that pushed this pretty cool
looking space plane across several miles
of dam raised concrete launch rail
and then it went and it was the big sled
had like 20 or 30 V2 V2 rocket engines
in it and then we get this thing up to
supposedly High Mach and it would get
near escape velocity and it would skip
across the top of the Earth's atmosphere
go over New York and they were going to
drop a a radioactive dirty bomb which
was they had a bunch of radioactive
silicate that they were using from their
heavy water project and they were going
to drop that thing over New York and try
to paralyze New York because that's what
they were using as a port to ship all
the stuff out it wouldn't have probably
worked
I think a New Yorkers probably wouldn't
have known what radioactive silicate was
and said oh if I could get back to work
and a lot of them would have died of
cancer
and but but the war effort would have
continued I don't think they would have
stopped because somebody dropped silicon
on them
um
but it was an amazing plane
I'm not sure it would have worked
um different guys have crunched the
numbers and saying there wasn't enough
thrust other guys have said no it
probably would have worked
um
but that's damn near a space shuttle
in the 40s that's pretty good man
yeah I think they came up with [__] like
I said I think they came up to [__] a
lot earlier than maybe we yeah imagine I
think the problem mostly is not so much
the inventing of it because the
principle of it is there but how to mass
produce it how to like you know make it
so it's not cost prohibitive I think
that's kind of like the main hurdle that
you have to overcome most of the time
yeah they were working on it but but if
they were working on it in France
D-Day happened and they had to stop
production although I think they killed
production right before D-Day anyway
I think they were running out of money
like I said cost prohibitive
yeah it happens yeah
but um but yeah okay so uh so the first
theory was that he actually just jumped
off the train or
disappeared himself like you know
willingly and went and killed himself
somewhere I'm not entirely buying that
like I said I just don't think that he
would have done that
um at that period in time
I've also heard another theory which
um I don't think I buy this one either
but apparently somebody somewhere found
a little note in a library someplace
that
that he had actually died in Chicago in
1897 I think something like that like
six or seven years after he supposedly
disappeared and that he had voluntarily
gone into hiding uh because his family
asked him to because he was gay
and I'm like
no I'm not really buying that either
um I just kind of feel like
I don't know I kind of feel like because
of all of his the inventions and
everything like that and he thought he
was going to make a lot of money was
like his wife knew about it and
everything like that and I kind of feel
like he would have wanted them if he was
gonna fake his death for example he
would have wanted his family he had a
wife and kids he would have wanted his
family to benefit from his inventions I
would have thought so it would kind of
it would seem kind of shitty for him to
like disappear I don't know you know I
didn't know the guy but he didn't really
what year was this again 1890s
and this is Europe
no it wasn't because he's gay there was
a lot of gay stuff man
yeah I mean it was illegal obviously and
they'd put you in jail if they call you
because Oscar Wilde went to jail yeah
but there was a lot of it and and people
knew about it and
People Protected family members and
stuff you know what I mean they just
didn't say anything and the thing about
is like even like I don't even know
there's no evidence that he actually
even was gay and like even if he was
it's like I just feel like that's not a
good enough excuse for him it's just
like no disappear himself
or whatever there were a lot of gay
people and they didn't you know come to
an ill you know
what was a good what's a good way to put
it then you can just come up missing and
their families didn't [__] with them
that bad especially if they were Rich it
probably was harder for a poor person
rich people were more tolerant of that
kind of stuff well it's always harder
for a poor person than in now you know
what I mean which people tend to be more
sophisticated they're like oh well yeah
do you think these rich people were not
really [__]
in any danger having anybody looked down
on them they were already right they're
like I got money
right well that's the thing you have
[__] you money you can do whatever the
[__] you want because it's like what's
anybody gonna say to you you're just
like bye yeah
you don't have anything to lose really
you know what I mean like it's not like
somebody's gonna come in and you're
fired you're gonna like you know be
sleeping on a bench or something like
that it's like that's not gonna happen
to them so they're not like really
worried about it
so yeah so I'm not buying suicide and
I'm not buying faking his own death for
various reasons I'm not really buying
them so I'm not saying it's impossible
I'm just saying I don't buy it it's
unlikely
uh another uh theory that I think Ben
alluded to earlier was that his brother
Albert killed him
now notably Albert was the last person
to see him alive uh he did say that he
took him to the train station and
notably he was the only person that said
that he for sure saw him get on that
train even though he wasn't on that
train presumably so I don't know see
that's the thing I don't want to like I
said you know they're all dead now but
um the family did absolutely not believe
they're like Albert wouldn't have done
that he just won he didn't have a motive
because I think a lot of people said
it's remember because remember how I
said their mom had died and like left
them that house and stuff but
um both Albert and Louis were as far as
I know were pretty financially
successful they didn't like they weren't
desperate they didn't need the money and
even if Albert had bumped off Louie
Louie's share of the house would have
gone to his wife and kids not to Albert
so there really wasn't any reason for
him necessarily unless Albert thought oh
he's got that invention and if I patent
that [__] then I mean that's possible
but I don't know like the family were
like they had a really good relationship
they didn't there was really no reason
for him to kill him but I don't know it
does it is slightly slightly suspicious
that really it's only we only have
Albert's word for it as far as I know
that he got on that train because he
apparently was not he either didn't get
on that train or he got off somewhere
it's like and no one noticed him and he
got off somewhere like he jumped off or
he was was killed on the train somewhere
and like nobody noticed because he for
sure did not get off of it I think he
was killed and then put on the train
maybe in a box with the luggage
and then when they got to their
destination where they were steal his
luggage they loaded him off the off with
the rest of the luggage yeah that's
probably what happened I think it was a
team of people
it just sounds suspicious this isn't the
work of one man
well and see if it's a dude killing
himself he can't dispose of his own body
it's not the work of one man yeah
because notably they never found the
body right that's the big giveaway right
there now see this is this is where the
Thomas Edison stuff comes in yeah nobody
is saying well as far as I know as far
as I know nobody is saying that Thomas
Edison himself wait I went there and
killed the dude I got a cop I grew up
with in here man he's got to investigate
into these techniques [__] grafters
if there's no body in a situation like
this that's the work of a team isn't it
a man can't dispose of his own body
and if he took himself to another
location to kill himself you'd find the
body eventually there too he didn't kill
himself that's unlikely and he was
murdered
and I'm saying because the evidence of
the body wasn't left behind and there's
no luggage of [__] it was done by a team
I'm kind of leaning toward it so I like
I said I don't know about Edison but it
is notable that Thomas Edison did indeed
patent his uh what is it called
kinetoscope kinetogram whatever graph or
whatever it's called
um really not that long
uh after Louis laprince's disappearance
was it it's the exact same design
almost almost uh it was very very
similar now he did know obviously he had
eyes everywhere so he knew that Louis
laprince was working on that [__] the
thing about it I don't know I I'm kind
of of two minds about this because in on
the one hand Thomas Edison is very well
known for stealing other people's ideas
and like taking credit for it and kind
of strong arming not necessarily killing
or beating up or anything like that but
he did have what they called a goon
squad
that would kind of go and intimidate
people yeah intimidate people into like
selling the rights to their stuff and
things like that and like I said he
would also use the legal system kind of
like a bludgeon uh you know in the
broader sense just so he could make more
money for his own self in modern term
terminology this would be [__]
private security or in industrial spies
and Industrial yeah industrial agents
this was definitely and and it's not
crazy I mean it does I mean [__] like I
said if you have History Channel or if
you have Hulu because it's on there now
it's been going on watch yeah what even
watch the food the Built America or
whatever it is there's like two or three
seasons of it and some of that [__] even
if it was just like with corn flakes or
Donuts or some [__] like that [__] got
ugly like sometimes when they were like
competing for a different because it's
money it's you know and if big money is
involved and you have a good idea and
you're afraid somebody else is going to
take it then yeah people will do some
extreme [__] Howard Hughes had a
security agency working underneath him
that he created and they're [__]
loyal to the damn death and they were
all staffed by Mormons and um they were
better than they were the best
intelligence agency in the world with
the highest level of Technology the CIA
and the FBI did everything they could to
catch up with with hughes's technology
and a lot of the stuff that the FBI did
was a copy of what Hughes was doing
Howard Hughes and he had this
sophisticated intelligence apparatus
and strangely enough the way Howard
Hughes was
the purpose of this intelligence agency
this private intelligence agency was to
keep an eye on all his girlfriends
that's some [__] man
make sure that [__] ain't cheating on
me
where is she
does something
it's something already yeah he was a
collector of women
that he didn't sleep with
it's weird but they're not allowed to go
sleep with other people no even though
no no he's just collected him he'd
collect all these little stars and put
them in these [__] hotels and then
just have spies watch them
and not even make movies with them
and then the second date you know then
the second he got reports back yeah she
got a boyfriend she's fired
he was mentally ill he had a bunch of
metal well yeah but we did a show we did
do it yeah multiple head injuries he's a
fascinating character yeah
little head injuries LCD man he had some
uh he had some problems yeah big time
but you know he he was insulated from it
quite a bit because of all the money he
had obviously so that's that's what
happens when you can live in your own
movie theater for a year and just be
there naked pissing in a bottle and
talking to people on top
you're watching movies 24 hours a day
and sleeping in there then that's see if
you were poor you'd be on your borders
yeah and they would take you away and
put you and they'd cops would take you
away yeah but you're rich you're just
allowed yeah oh he's just eccentric he
lived in that opulent theater for a year
I didn't want anybody to see him
well I'm sure probably nobody wanted to
see him because he looked like pooping
in jars and like walk around naked with
all these fingernails and [__] I don't
think well he's pooping someone you're
kissing in the jars
yeah he wasn't pooped he wasn't [__]
in the jar I read the book He's probably
just [__] on the floor no I think
there was a I think there was a bathroom
but um that he would go to
but for so he didn't want to go to it to
take a piss though he was just piss in
his milk bottles
you drink milk if you pissed it back in
the bottle did he ever drink any
accident he would line it up you know
that happens when it when it was when
when it had piss and he would line it up
on the on the outside of the aisle of
the extreme like right of the aisle so
his servants could come in there and
pick it up
bet they loved that bet that was their
favorite day of the work week oh boy
it's pea bottle day yeah can't wait yeah
yeah Hughes was a good man though I
don't maybe think he's not a bad man he
just he had a lot of head injuries from
motorcycles well yeah it wasn't his
fault necessarily because well some of
it was his fault because he did do all
that Daredevil [__] and that's kind of
his own yeah well another thing is is
every time he'd wreck an airplane and
get a [__] head injury he would
[__] have his [__] henchmen pull
him out of the hospital he would refuse
treatment over and over and over again
yeah so that probably is that was really
part of what it was he was real
Headstrong
he probably didn't have like his skull
was in there he was kind of like
rattling around and [__] like [__]
loose puzzle pieces you know
but yeah so okay so the thing about it
like I said Thomas Edison he did have a
history of doing
this kind of thing not necessarily
killing people
but having kind of like a team of goons
that would go intimidate people
so it's also I think that there was a
witness account
of I guess like one of the lawyers that
was supposed to I think one of the
lawyers that was supposed to represent
Louis laprince like when he was gonna do
the patent because he was coming over to
do it
um was talking to Edison like was seen
talking to Edison at some point or like
later went to work for Edison so I think
people are
thinking that maybe Thomas Edison if he
didn't
maybe he didn't say like oh go kill that
dude or make him disappear which
he did I mean that worked but
I don't so I don't know if he actually
had a hand in that or if he just was
like woohoo like if he just it happened
other than like you know without his
influence and then he just took
advantage of it it does seem that Thomas
Edison for sure was the person who stood
to benefit the most from him
disappearing now on the other hand
there were other people as I mentioned
it was very much in the Zeitgeist at the
time of
people working on motion picture cameras
so it doesn't it's it's not too crazy to
think that other people might have been
working on a similar thing
and maybe you know he wouldn't have been
too concerned about oh this guy just has
another one but
like you said maybe he had industrial
spies
maybe one of the lawyers that had been
working with Louis laprince was secretly
working for Edison or like went behind
his back and went to Edison and told him
hey he's doing this that and the other
and then Thomas that is like oh I want
that [__] and then like they worked that
out it's not crazy like I said the kind
of the industrialist back then did do
this kind of [__]
so you know Thomas Edison he's dead uh
and like I said he can't sue me but it's
um his ghost can see me but um it's not
it's far-fetched but probably not as
far-fetched as
as it would have been if you were
talking about somebody else you know
what I'm saying he had the power he had
yeah that's what I mean he had the means
and he definitely he for sure had a
motive and not too long after Louis Le
Prince disappeared
um he did patent a movie camera and went
around the country like projecting and
stuff projecting movies with it and it
was almost exactly like the one that
Louis the prince was gonna was gonna do
so you know make it that which you will
I'm not I'm not really sure I don't know
maybe it just happened that Louis
laprince disappeared under different
completely random circumstances and
Thomas Edison just took advantage of
that [__] because he would have but
I don't know the timing of it just seems
a little suspicious to me that's that's
all I'm saying
now
um there's also another possibility
which I kind of it's weird because I
kind of feel like a lot of people bring
up the suicide thing
um you know the went into hiding because
he was gay thing uh the brother killing
him thing
um and Edison killing him thing but a
lot of people don't seem to point out
that it's possible that he could have
just been the victim of just a random
ass crime
um one theory that I did see put forward
on because this isn't mentioned on a lot
of things but I did see somebody like
point this out
they said what could have happened was
that for whatever reason maybe Albert
did take him to the station and did see
him like appear to get on the train or
look like he was getting on the train
but then maybe after Albert left
um Louie was just kind of like oh [__] I
forgot something or I think I'm going to
take a later train like for whatever
reason they're like it's possible that
he could have gotten off that train
Albert didn't see him get off the train
and then he took a later one and when he
was on the later train he might have
been attacked by just a random
person like he could have just been the
random victim of a crime and what
happened to his luggage that's what I
was going to say that's the only thing
yeah because it did happen like people
did get robbed and [__] like that but he
apparently did have a lot of luggage
with him so it would have like you said
it would have had to be a gang of
robbers and maybe they didn't know so
and that's the thing like why would they
have attacked him specifically unless he
was just like a random victim it does
seem like industrial Espionage it does
seem like that I mean I'm just I know it
sounds kind of crazy but that does
really seem like I mean he had a
valuable it also sounds kind of it's
possible too that his brother could have
done it okay because it is a little bit
suspicious that we only have his
brother's word for it that yeah he did
get on that train because nobody else
saw him that's a good possibility though
too maybe his brother killed him before
he even got to this [__] train
station that's what I mean it said yeah
I totally saw him get on the train it's
like and like I said I don't know
because the family was like no
absolutely not like he wouldn't have
done that but you know and they knew him
so I guess they know better than me and
they wouldn't have a motive but yeah but
oh now the motive maybe though like I
mentioned earlier it might not have had
to do with the mom's estate because like
I said he wouldn't have got the money
anyway if his brother had died like the
wife and the kid would have got it but
maybe he wanted to take advantage of the
inventions himself because he knew that
it was going to make a lot of money
unlikely but like I said I just don't I
don't know I just feel like that how
would he how how could he have played
that off
right because and why that's his brother
yeah he's like and they were apparently
uh he's gone so I'm gonna pick up his uh
his work on this [__] camera and this
dude didn't sound like he knew anything
about cameras and the thing about it was
that the family as it ended up the
family didn't benefit because because he
disappeared they didn't find his body so
they had to wait seven years to declare
him dead before they could do anything
with his patents or his inventions and
by that time it was way too late because
Edison had already done that [__] Edison
would have had enough lawyers
that it had the foresight too saying
well if he comes up missing it'll be
seven years before they can do anything
anyway that's see that's what makes me
suspicious is that had it been another
thing had his brother done it or had you
know if his brother had okay just
hypothetically if his brother had done
it to take over his inventions he would
have made sure the buddy was found
because it's like well you want the body
to be found so that you know that he's
dead so that like you can have access to
his stuff because it's like if he wasn't
found which is what ended up happening
then no one you they had a law there was
like a I don't think this is uh on the
books anymore but they had a law where
it's like oh if you had filed a patent
or bloody blah like the family members
couldn't use that patent until seven
years had passed like if the person had
disappeared like after they were
declared dead so nobody in the family
got [__] from him just disappearing
so I kind of feel like that sort of
takes the air out of that motive
because they didn't get any benefit from
it yeah you know what I'm saying
so
that and anything else like suicide or
even like just a random gang of robbers
you'd think that they would have found
the body because the thing about it was
let's just say again hypothetically
which I don't think was the case but
let's just say he decided I'm just going
to end it all and he jumped off the
train well the train it was an Express
train just from it was regular service
you know what I mean it was a regular
route and they looked all along that
route they looked in the train they
looked all over the place they didn't
find anything
so I just kind of feel like they would
have found his body eventually if
someone didn't kind of like disappear
him on purpose he was disappearing on
purpose I mean a team of dudes it's the
only thing I feel like yeah no I don't
know because it's kind of hard to get
rid of a body not that I would know
firsthand or anything I would say I
would say something like Edison's
[__] intelligence agencies may have
done something like that there his
industrial agencies may have done
something like that whether or not he
gave the order to do it I don't know
might have been somebody Rogue in there
yeah that's what I'm saying yeah we
could say that it's still industrial
Espionage but it might not have been
Edison yeah might have been somebody
else it might have been somebody else
trying to take advantage of somebody in
Edison's outfit just doing it on their
own just doing it on there the boss will
like that I'm gonna take this guy this
right that's another possibility I'll
get rewarded and [__] then the boss
won't know how I even got it done that
kind of [__]
yeah he's like oh that guy just I don't
you know yeah look what I got don't ask
any questions boss right and Edison was
the type of guy I'd be like okay yeah
I'm not looking at gift horse in the
mouth right or the world's first movie
but something like that
make sure you get your bonus this year
you know that kind of [__]
Ben said and actually I thought of this
but I thought of this too said they
might have argued about him and his
brother they mean uh about him moving to
America a friendship very passionate
that's true they could have fought and
Louis and got killed accidentally and
then the brother panicked and loaded the
luggage and buried the body that's also
another possibility I was thinking about
that earlier like when I was watching a
documentary about it and that's another
theory that I don't see brought up that
much it is possible that the brother
might have killed him but just like like
accidentally like I said just in the
course of an argument or something and
then he freaked out and hit it but it
just does seem like
what's most likely though
well see I'm kind of thinking see I'm
thinking that the SP industrial
Espionage whether it was Edison or not
because
a lot of people knew that he was working
on that [__] A lot of people knew that
he was the first back then they knew um
and then sadly like the knowledge was
lost but we're trying to kind of like
it's it's trying to kind of come back
out nowadays which is good because I
feel really bad for this dude there's a
motive there you know yeah and and
Edison for sure benefited yeah from The
Disappearance big time I mean he didn't
even wait I don't even think it was a
year
it might not even been a year like is
there any way to know it could have been
like you said the brother killed him by
accident and then hit it
we're just talking about likelihood
you know what I mean that may have
happened but I think it's less likely
yeah you know
more likely industrial Espionage it's
just the lack of the body and the and
the and there being no trace of any of
the luggage yeah see people kill people
all the time and they get caught right
you know what I mean like oh I don't
know you know I don't know where that
dude is
I took him to the train station and they
said well the luggage isn't there and
then they just keep digging and digging
and they yeah I did it you know yeah
eventually they're gonna find out
[Laughter]
he hid he hit it he hid the body on a
certain route or he tried to hide it out
in the damn Farmer's field somewhere
well guess what there's a farmer and he
finds it you know I mean they just
they'd have found the body most likely
yeah even back then I mean yeah
especially in that era they didn't have
ATVs and vehicles that could cross you
know they could cross country too well
so he couldn't have take he couldn't
have hit if he tried to hide that body
from from using a motor car it would
have been pretty close to a road and he
would have to have a shovel
and time and to dig a hole and
I just don't think so man no
yeah I'm not really the families were
like no way is he a suspect
they're probably right they would know
more than us
yeah and that's I don't know I think as
it all starts going towards industrial
espionage
yeah I think so I mean that's kind of
what I'm leaning more into it he
disappeared and sold the luggage he must
have not gotten on the train or no he's
the brother said he got on the train the
brother said he got it okay but it's
possible like I said that he could have
gotten off the train after the brother
left the train station for example maybe
um that could have happened but if it
was industrial Espionage they knew he
was going on a train and maybe they knew
what time he'd be leaving or the team
Waits until he shows up and then they
board at the same time that he that he's
going to board
and uh then they have this whole plan
where they're gonna kill him put him in
a damn box or a [__] yeah maybe they
were like waiting for him on the train
and like that's why nobody really saw
him yeah and they all have tickets and
and they have a way to change the
luggage or they or or they take his
ticket and use his ticket to collect his
luggage and he's in his luggage right
now you know what I mean and that's how
you get him off the train
and maybe you've already bribed somebody
in the railroad because he's a friend of
Edison
you know something like that yeah Edison
might own that railroad we're making
Edison sound like Specter yeah
you know some some of those those were
oligarchs and they owned all I know
that's what I mean it's like they were
kind of like on a smaller scale like
they had a lot of money and they had a
lot of the Confederates Hughes owned so
much stuff Hughes wasn't sure what he
owned
here's what one day in one of the one of
the uh biographies I wrote of him is
written by his right hand man who's one
of security guys I forgot what his name
was
he he just called him boss and boss man
was flipping out about some company that
was coming up with some new sensors that
would have [__] helped would have
like uh done something about missile
guidance
and he says we have to stop this company
at all [__] costs and they're doing
this investigations they're trying to
figure out who this company is and then
later they find out well wait a minute
we own a company that owns a company
that owns a company that owns that
company that's your company boss he goes
oh okay
it's like it's just let's just assume
you own everything yeah yeah okay just
that's that's the starting point yes you
own that yeah okay he chilled out it
took him a couple days to figure out
that they owned it
because it was part of some
conglomerations that were oh because he
had twisted his empire into a knot
to avoid a bunch of legal problems and
to uh help Avid taxes and [__] like that
he wasn't sure what he owed it was
running on autopilot and just growing
without him even
he just had put good bosses and [__] in
charge of these companies and they uh
they ratchet real well and they would
just grow and grow and buy other
companies and with company money and
even the FBI wasn't sure how big
hughes's Empire was it was big
that's crazy yeah it's crazy
didn't know he owed
I could see that happening once your
company got big enough
I mean [__] I would if any of you guys
watch uh there's a really good YouTube
channel called company band
where he talks about he just says like
12 15 minute videos about different
companies and some of the
companies in there he does a series
that's called it's called like bigger
than you know or something like that and
he talks about these kind of big usually
food conglomerates but not always that
own [__] tons of like different brands
that you weren't even aware were like
all owned by the same company
and every time I see that I always think
to myself man what a [__] that
paperwork must be because it's just like
here's this big company and then we own
50 bajillion little companies companies
with like all these 50 bajillion
different brands like every single thing
they each have their own employees and
they have their marketing team and they
have it's just like Jesus Christ it's
just like I it makes my head hurt
thinking about it yeah like all how
complex it is but um but yeah okay so
here's another little uh little factoid
so apparently in 2003
a photograph was uncovered from the
Paris photo archives the police archives
this photo was of an unidentified
drowning victim from around this time
period
I have seen the photo
and I will admit it does look like Louis
laprince they pulled it out of the sin I
believe
however uh some sources I've said said
this the height was different because
remember I said Louis laprince was
pretty tall like for example six foot
three or six foot four something like
that like unusually tall for the time
that time that's weird so yeah he was
super tall
so um this victim was apparently
significantly shorter than that but I
really the photo is just of his face and
you know he's dead and like he drowned
and stuff so it's kind of hard but he
does kind of look like him so I get it
but the weird thing about that is that
even if that was Louis Le Prince
they found him in Paris
he left from Dijon like so how did he
get to Paris because nobody saw him on
the train you know what I'm saying
um there's that and also like if
somebody killed like did somebody drown
him or but like I said it's probably not
him because of the height difference
although I will admit that the face does
look very much like him but it's kind of
hard to tell because he's dead you know
what I mean because there are some
pictures of Louis laprince uh you know
one when he there was a couple when he
was younger and there was one when he
was older like not too long before he
died but I don't know so I'm pretty sure
that that's not him even though it does
resemble him because even if it was him
it opens up a whole other possibility
like how the hell did he even get to
Paris in the first place
like because he wasn't on the train like
that not anybody saw like he didn't get
off at the station or anything
so nobody said nobody knows how he could
have been there so that just could have
been a random guy they don't know who
that guy is
all right so um so we've determined that
Thomas Edison is probably a murderer
I mean maybe not I just like I don't
know it sounds crazy when you say it
like that but I don't know I don't know
I don't know if that's true it's like a
million different things could have
happened but I'm just saying that
industrial Espionage whether Edison was
behind it or not I think was probably
it's likely because it seems the timing
just seems so strange like I'm going to
America and I'm gonna and I have this
new fangled thing it's a movie camera
and I'm gonna show it to everybody and
get get the patent and make all this
money and then suddenly he's
suspiciously disappears and they never
find his body and they never find any of
his stuff and they just like that just
seems a little odd to me yeah it doesn't
necessarily mean it was
Edison or he knew anything about it it
might have been private contractors that
that sold [__] to companies right you
know they just did [__] on their own
um might have been a French
[__] industrial Espionage yeah it
could have been anybody it could have
been anybody hey he's going to go to
America and give them this patent we
can't have that that's another
possibility like that's what I mean it
didn't necessarily have to be Edison it
could have been and it might have been
some French film company or some French
company like we want that [__] we want
that right it might have been something
like that sure
and uh you know France will have the
first you know camera you know it might
have been something like that yeah and
there might have for all you know it had
the fresh [__] oligarchs and people
inside the government like that's right
yeah we're not gonna let that go to
America
so it could have been that you don't
know but I would say Espionage
industrial Espionage yeah I mean that
like I said that seems like the most
yeah
yeah the most beneficial on the part of
whoever would have to have been done by
a team so that just means espionage
but yeah so anyway it's like I'm I'm
just really glad that now
um even though Louis laprince is
probably like he's not a household name
like Thomas Edison is obviously but I
kind of feel like knowledge about him is
kind of slowly seeping into the culture
and that makes me happy because it just
I don't know why but this like well I do
know why but it's it just bummed me out
so much that he's like I he invented the
first movie camera like a significant
amount of time before Edison claimed
credit for it he was making movies in
when Jack the Ripper was running around
he was filming his little family like I
was like that's amazing and it you know
it sucks that he didn't get any credit
for it and he just [__] disappeared
off the face of the Earth and then
everyone just kind of forgot about him
like until recently
so
I mean I I kind of hope if there's an
afterlife or something he's looking down
going oh hey I'm not forgotten after all
because man that's really shitty that's
really shitty to like invent something
that is so ubiquitous and like so
important to like the world culture at
large and like you don't get any credit
for it like some other [__] like
took credit for it and you just ended up
like completely forgotten about that's
like really a bummer but yeah
all right so I guess we're gonna wrap it
up because it's nine o'clock and I'm
getting sleepy yeah and I got some [__]
to do before I go to bed again like
always but uh yeah so thanks everybody
for dropping by this evening hopefully
you found this show as interesting as I
did I feel like that's right very
interesting show yeah
um yeah we'll be back for Friday we're
gonna do the Sidetrack show on Friday
night like normal because I don't think
we're going out on Friday are we yeah
maybe maybe not maybe maybe not we don't
know uh so yeah so but we'll definitely
do a show on Friday night like we
usually do so hopefully you guys can
join us for that we can talk about all
kind of fun stuff and have some more
drinks because I want to get up and go
to work in the morning uh but yeah so
remember to like and share and comment
and all that good stuff for the
algorithm and we'll see you guys again
on Friday night good night